[Musik]
er kletterte ungesichert in die
steilsten wette er balancierte
gefährlich nahe am abgrund der
bergsteiger ueli steck
[Musik]
die meisten pcs und macs was
dahintersteckt geht viel steht das
spielt oder
gemacht irgendwie herr uhl forderte im
focus zusammen
es macht mich labor lagen
[Musik]
er war wohl der beste mit dem ich je
geklettert bin wir die wände hinauf
rannte
fiete als alle anderen juli steck
schaffte an den größten ort wenden
geschwindigkeitsrekorde
[Musik]
vor drei jahren stürzte er im himalaya
1000 meter in die tiefe und starb
überlappen und umso oder mangan zu gold
weshalb suchen menschen ihre grenzen und
warum gehen sie so hohe risiken ein
was hat orly steckt angetrieben
[Musik]
kathmandu nepal
[Applaus]
am tag des unfalls war er zu ihm
unterwegs
robert busch der fotograf war nach
kathmandu gekommen um ueli stecks
expedition am everest fotografisch zu
dokumentieren
stattdessen erhielt er hier in kathmandu
die nachricht vom tod seines freundes
gleichzeitig muss ich sagen rückblick
und ich bin extrem froh dass ich da
einig sind sich also dafür ist das nicht
lösen aber das ist eine situation die
ich erinnere mich noch genau an den
moment als wir uns am flughafen trafen
und du sagst ist ich habe sehr schlechte
nachrichten denn die sherpa ein freund
von ueli metall überbrachte robert bosch
damals die todesnachricht so bekam es
die nachricht fünf minuten bevor ich
ankam
ja ich erhielt die information gerade
vor einer landung vielleicht eine halbe
stunde vorher so ein unglaublicher
moment
es ist noch nichts nach
das ist nicht passiert
[Musik]
der fotograf robert bosch ist selber
bergsteiger oft war er zusammen mit uli
hier in nepal
es ist 2009 10
zwei jahre nach orly stecks tod als wir
ihn in kathmandu treffen wir wollen
nochmals in das leben seines freundes
eintauchen verstehen warum er immer
wieder die herausforderung suchte foto
termin für einen guten zweck
robert bosch fotografiert für ein
schweizer hilfswerk
er dokumentierte die karriere von ueli
steck von anfang an
[Musik]
die krise hat noch nie
wer in einer der täter ist 20 meter hoch
war stundenkilometer wind und das inbild
rechtloser machen das funktioniert denn
nun auch da gibt es dann immer machst
normal dass ich habe dinge nämlich spürt
ich habe sorgen ausgelöst haben ich
gespürt und bei hat ihn im gesicht über
grund war man da jetzt noch jeder hätten
wir sie daran dass ich und dann
irgendwie und hält eine verknüpfung wie
man so schnell machen und noch keine
seite geladen ist es dass bender nano
und und positiv für ihre freundschaften
abnahme situation zusammen erlebt
[Musik]
ueli steck wie man ihn kannte allein und
ohne sichern das seil in einer riesigen
wand die zähne waren die ich die chemie
die 100 prozent überzeugt dass ihr mann
habe daher immer bei absturz steht im
moment nicht im vorfeld muss ich das
ganz klar analysiert also ist es möglich
ist es nichts was ich nicht kann noch
richtig ankam wusste ja was für eine
situation dass dieser mangel für die iss
[Musik]
ich glaube es ist da drüben david
göttler deutscher profi bergsteiger
kannte orly steck sehr gut
[Musik]
raus gut super super alles mit geklagt
danke danke du bist jetzt müssen morgen
genau jetzt erst mal war ich hier meine
punkte
ich war in japan als wittmann basislager
und zwar genau der ort wo ich ein jahr
vorher im uhr live und dann kam die
nachricht dass der uli ums leben
gekommen es am nutze ja es reicht also
oder mir jetzt einfach zu dem boden den
füßen weggerissen
die senioren haben angefangen war war
sie aufgelöst aber befindet sich dann in
so einem vakuum erstmal man begreift es
nicht total surreal
trotz des todes seines freundes macht
david göttler weiter mit dem bergsteigen
schon in wenigen tagen will errichtung
everest aufbrechen
für ihn der ueli steck absolut
einzigartig
dieses commitment weil sie in dieser
ausgesetzt zeit zu gehen mit seiner
konsequenz mit zu einem minimalismus
dann an ein sicherheitsnetzen quasi die
da irgendwas noch quasi wenn irgendwas
außerplanmäßig läuft irgendwie greifen
das ist einfach für mich die dieses
außergewöhnliche an diese an der
unternehmung gewesen kurz vor dem
aufbruch ins everest gebiet wieder
passiert ein tragischer berg und fallen
drei junge profi bergsteiger sind in
einer lawine ums leben gekommen es waren
könner wie ueli bergsteigen fordert das
schicksal heraus und ist immer ein
hoffen auf gutes gelingen
[Musik]
m
robert bosch und david göttler planen
gemeinsam richtung everest zu reisen
hi
[Musik]
billi bierling ist chronistin des
achttausender bergsteigens ein eintrag
in ihrer himalaya datenbank gehört für
alpinisten wie david göttler zum ritual
vor einer expedition
es wird auch festgehalten wer mit wem
unterwegs ist die haben sich wirklich
getroffen also ich weiß es noch
ich war mit dem bulli abendessen bevor
er vor zwei jahren zum everest ist ja da
waren wir alle sondern haben wir uns
unterhalten und dann habe ich ihm gesagt
hey ich freue mich so dass das museum
von david so gut klappt und dann hat er
wirklich so ein strahlen in den augen
gehabt habe endlich habe ich jemanden
gefunden der genau die gleiche oder das
geld die gleiche trainings weise hatten
ich vorher noch irgendwie auf den
anderen oder keiner anderen berge und
wann kommst du dann um die fanbasis
labahn ich bin auch ganz wenig nur im
walde server na ja also ich gehe mal
runter nach harwich manchmal überrascht
mich selber irgendwie das ist eben wie
kann es sein dass jetzt drei freunde
irgendwie ums leben gekommen sind und
ich trotzdem diese motivation zu spüren
jetzt ein gericht zu gehen und nicht
wirklich darauf freuen tvi diese zwei
gefühls irgendwie extreme die da
irgendwie in einem bringen sind und weiß
nicht warum das so ist aber
kann sein das ist so ich meine wir sind
sicher auch so gut zeigt immer die
bergsteiger eben quasi im verdrängen von
von solchen ereignissen
[Musik]
gehst du auch nach lukla ja ich bin dein
pilot recht das ist gut
vom flughafen kathmandu aus geht es in
einem einstündigen flug mit dem
helikopter ins chromebook das gebiet um
den everest
[Musik]
luckner ein gebirgs flughafen auf 2800
meter höhe
[Musik]
alle nepal reisenden kennen ihn
er gilt als der gefährlichste flughafen
der welt
[Musik]
hat sich anschaut wie hier landen müssen
in diesen in den bergen viele an den
plan geht irgendwie so steil bergauf ist
super kurz das ist halt und dann seid
berühmt-berüchtigt für immer wieder auf
irgendwelche und jetzt gerade letzte
woche war hier beim staaten sieht man
nach oben der flieger irgendwie der hier
weil sie von der lange app oder
startbahn dann in dem fall abgekommen
ist
david göttler war oft mit ueli steck
hier im everest gebiet zum trainieren
und auch robert bosch war früher als
bergsteiger hier an den achttausendern
es was mir ein solches bild quasi hängen
bleibt sobald wir angefangen haben uns
zubewegen irgendwie sobald der in
bewegung war laufend oder am berg oder
dann war irgendwie so ist er wirklich so
ein schalter umgelegt worden ist und war
irgendwie so voll in seinem element
ich kann mich noch erinnern beim ersten
mal war ich echt brutal nervös technik
also wir laufen laufen laufen also es
ist wirklich laufen laufen oder es ist
schnell gehen oder es gibt sehr viele
quasi abstufung hin zu 25 kilometern
2000 höhenmeter david göttler filmt die
reisen mit steck für seine vorträge
also ich spüre die höhe von fast 5000
meter den steilen wird wie hier hinauf
zur lodge ueli steck kehrte immer an den
gleichen orten ein
so entstanden viele freundschaften er
macht mich fertig sechs stunden 36
minuten von heute zwei pässe ja darum
sind wir hungrig rennen zu kommen
hierher
jetzt trete jetzt trend nannte viel
glück
[Applaus]
ich habe immer schon echt so bisschen
lahm aus auf den bildern ein tracking
stock hier nur unterwegs bist noch um
titel ich habe dir wusste aber auch kein
pickel und ich habe mir das nicht
irgendwie geraten zur sicherheit sondern
einfach für besseres bildmaterial
irgendwie und heißt nein das brauche ich
zum geländes bildmaterial nicht passt
dann ist das auch egal
erfolg ist der hinsicht du brauchst
einfach schneller schuhe dann reichen
stadt aufgewachsen ist uli steckt im
emmental
seine eltern leben heute noch hier wie
auch einen oder mit seiner familie
oliva der jüngste von drei brüdern
gegangen hab es mir aber gar ein
bisschen einfach natürlich das was ich
natürlich dass sich die beiden brüder
von ueli haben als kinder eishockey
gespielt
oli gefiel das nicht nur schokolade
kommt noch heute die netiquette
damit lieferte er ist relativ einfach
der bauherr und ist nur gut wenn man
nicht nur hier und da muss man hier bei
diesem uhr herum oder ist nicht der
trainer
aber das tut er meditiert der großer
sorge sieht da bin ich das auch
gestorben
ja man sie aus aber die reaktionen der
kollegen mitgeteilt dass ledger posthum
noch gewonnen hat aber genau da der golf
macht du ein major ein elfmeter gab sie
nicht einfach dadurch stellt sie
oder flüssig dank praxis macht das wird
nicht einfach
[Musik]
obwohl ich schon echte traditionsreichen
oder weniger bis basiert
noch eben mit top 2 c oder du bist du
gerade
das ist doch eigentlich kameragurt
umgang und die situation aber nicht
drüber steht das ist zum beispiel und
sehe was was du was mitgekriegt dass
kommentar nicht los dass ich das ist
etwas das ist einfach nichts nach der
darum himmel für das plötzlich wie
geht's dir aber mit
[Musik]
damit wurde ueli steck weltberühmt mit
seinem geschwindigkeitsrekorden in der
eigernordwand
die ganze eigernordwand schaffte er 2007
in unglaublichen drei stunden 54 minuten
doch das war erst der anfang
buchhorn ist komisches gefühl kann ich
so cool und ich war wahnsinnig vater und
vier stunden oder und dass ich jetzt
irgendwie ganz neues und für mich als
komisches für die komischsten rat der
die stellung der benni nicht ganz so
optimal ich bin ja nicht
also irgendwie als sicher dass ich
nämlich liegt
[Musik]
und so geht er ein jahr darauf nochmals
für den zweiten versuch ist er noch
besser vorbereitet er trainierte noch
härter als vorher
im e mail inhalt leistungsorientiert das
abitur und die definieren ist sehr stark
übermächtig wie redest du bist ein
echter mehrwert das projekt ich will mir
erst einmal nicht so tun und da mal das
krad kaffee und das hat mich gestört und
das schon mit proxy sollte die normale
grund machen
[Musik]
diesmal ist er mehr als eine stunde
schneller
er braucht zwei stunden 47 minuten
[Musik]
keine zeitung die nicht über ihn und
seine rekorde geschrieben hätte
[Musik]
bereits elf nie verbogen hatte ich immer
authentisch bleibe mit den üblichen gang
als sich eine gruppe und was glaubt
gütern geschätztes von menschen für
projekte zelten es geschafft hacker
monitor schon irgendwie hier bis groß
ankündigen sondern fleißig braucht um
erfolgreich und das ist glaube schon
dass auch reale geschafft wo wollte
schmidt zu schätzen
bruno steck führte für seinen bruder die
geschäfte als dieser immer berühmter
wurde
daneben hat er eine immobilienfirma der
bullishe einig sehr sparsam klappt und
das trio die firma konkrete bevor das
los geht und wo sie bessere sprangen ist
ob sie das ist sehr großzügig und sarah
ist glasklar business class und vor der
ihn am arm ist sicher großer punkt sieht
ganz uhr vortrag sie von der rekener
machen für verschiedene organisationen
und anderes ist japan zurück sie wolle
zum teil und werden ganz karriere
begleitet
die speed rekorde am aigner machte noli
steck schnell zu einem der berühmtesten
bergsteiger einem gefragten vortrags
reisenden und interviewpartner
viele klettern gefährlicher mit einem
partner sich allein weil ich mich auf
einem anderen level bewegen
ich bereite mich minutiös vor bevor ich
etwas mache ich bin schweizer mache
alles schritt um schritt
seine sponsoren konnte er sich aussuchen
ist es leichter zu sagen das
interessiert mich du bist später ich
habe schon anfragen für 2011 aber
dezember ist in einem halben jahr ja das
ist voll
ich bin schon gebucht für 2011 schade
schreibt eine mail in moskau fragen alle
wann kommt endlich zu uns
ich komme gerne wenn du flexibel bist
findet doch ein datum für nächstes jahr
ist ein familienfest habe dass ich mir
das wohl nie co
das muss man akzeptieren und sondern ist
natürlich der trainingsfleiß oder
trainings mehr uhr
aber dann wird der öffentlichkeit nicht
was man macht aber letztlich am morgen
fünf steuer und auf dänisch zu erstellen
im koma liegende opfer das zur seite
ich glaube dass diese disziplin und
realistisch sehen
es blieb nicht beim speed record am 1
er wollte die schnellste zeit an allen
grossen nordwände der alpen an den
grunge horace im block gebiet und am
matterhorn
[Musik]
o
hallo
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht nachvollziehen das
nicht selber erlebt hat
wie werden wir nicht vorstellen was
passiert ist von ihnen hängt zwar wird
für das glaubt dass lichtschutz harz und
da macht man glaubt es ganzes land
[Musik]
eishockey gehört nach wie vor zum leben
von bruno staeck er war 15 jahre lang
profi mit dem zsc sogar schweizer
meister mir braucht doch nicht klappen
eigentlich und das trikot und
wichtigsten abstand ihrer freunde dort
der freitag steht dann kann ich ja egal
was man auch schon zu recht dank rascher
folge
heute ist der trainer zu hause im ehc
burgdorf ehrgeiz liegt in der familie
orly war nicht der einzige der
zielstrebig auf einen erfolg
hinarbeitete ich bin ich dann hier
hielten die aus holland dort kennt sie
ich möchte den tiefen hat
[Applaus]
und ernährungsgewohnheiten mit den am
morgen fluege.de schwachpunkte die zehn
menschen
[Applaus]
zurück in lukla in nepal
robert bosch und david göttler warten
auf den weitertransport
der pilot maurizio pollini war ein
weiterer weggefährte von ueli steck
[Musik]
normalerweise arbeitet maurizio pollini
im engadin hilft aber während der
bergsteiger saison in nepal aus
der rolli hanglage team-arzt nepal
keiner klären und der emsaue die schweiz
für kleinere projekt und in dem jahr als
erste bergsteiger projekt li mit den
anteilig liedermacher und die anlage
sehr gefreut bin ich auch sehr nervös
sie mit der man soll uns starke
bergsteiger können
ich selber mache das everest basecamp
auf 5400 meter
[Musik]
es ist april und die ersten everest
expeditionen sind schon da maurizio
pollini ist hier eine institution
er war der erste dem eine rettung auf
7800 meter höhe gelang auch am todestag
von ueli steck war er im einsatz
ich bin dem tag im 96 ii am trainieren
mich akklimatisieren und den weißen or
death valley co also heinz mit
telefoniert von der basis im smi parat
machen
der früheste bisher am everest mehari
details parat macht mit dem nachbarn als
rettungsspezialist zum online rettig
machen und wo der lack panoro es handelt
sich um die letzte mixed
einen kurzen moment schockiert sie aber
denn da hatte ich konzentriert mein job
mit job ist sie einfach die räte
tourenführer
er fliegt mit uns nochmals hoch dorthin
wo er seinen toten freund werden musste
am 19 zuhinterst am riesigen combo
gletscher everest lotse und nutze bilden
hier ein hufeisen dessen überschreitung
im höhenbergsteigen als eines der
letzten ungelösten probleme gilt
[Musik]
das ganze gelände
herzhaft körper
[Musik]
wir sind auf 7000 meter so hoch hinauf
können nur wenige fliegen
das lager 2 auf 6400 meter von hier aus
war damals uhr league gestartet allein
war es zu viel risiko
ich glaube nicht dass der uli mehr
riskierte das andere manager der hat das
gemacht wonach dafür trainiert hat und
ich hatte mit meinen job auf glichen in
der flüge rey toni auch der mensch also
der pilot der maschine auch am limit
stoße mit der usb stick aufmachte
megathemen heißt nicht dass mehrere
einfach selbstmörder sind mit lebend
einfacher so intensiv ist ja das leben
so wie es für uns passt
[Musik]
basa der ausgangspunkt für alle everest
ratings
[Musik]
nach dem helikopter flog treffen sich
hier die drei weggefährten von ueli
steck wie sie zum beispiel bei der
flanke
oberthur aber der heber des knotens wie
war das damals wurde der meister nach
dem abschluss von bully weiß der bank
oder das wort es war eigentlich gut 300
millionen unterhalt für ein großes ja
o
als erstes ein gefunden werden in dem
2007 beobachtet ob sie ihn ein stück
sein das weiß der name pixi und der
erste war monique liegt dann ist
eigentlich dass das 2 dass er mit dem
[Musik]
franzosen yannick mit jannik aber
derjenige ist ein ja hätte ja nicht in
lloret stücke bekannt in herrlicher
wieder der schädling ist aber der ist ja
mal von wird kaiser bei diesen haben
stürzt und kennen ja etwas komisch das
ist nicht souverän am limit und darüber
das stimmt auch das passiert auch ganz
viel umfang bergsteiger passieren eine
stange absolute limit ist das macht ihn
mein größter respekt vor dem situationen
wo es warm war es bei gott das limit und
oft das meistens passiert eine berichtet
derweil am anfang steigt man eben hier
wir hatten damals irgendwie hier unser
lager und da ist eigentlich so her da
kommst du hier nicht überall so fällt es
jetzt nicht am anfang hier der muss weit
oben gewesen sein weil änderungen
gefordert
[Musik]
juli steck war bereits berühmt in europa
aber noch nicht in amerika er reiste
deshalb für ein kletter projekt in den
yosemite nationalpark in kalifornien
floriert und so bezog dazu das ist sehr
wichtig die bekannteste route am granit
turm l kapitalist hinaus 2010 wollte
ulrich steck auch hier einen speed
rekordversuche zusammen mit alex holt
den heute wohl berühmtesten kletterer
der welt
also ich würde im yosemite traf war ich
viel jünger hat er kein geld
juni war bereits so etwas wie eine
legende bekannt und respektiert
ich war beeindruckt fand es toll mit
jemandem seines kalibers zu klettern
er war inspirierend so hart und seriös
wie er trainierte sonst niemand ich
dachte wahrscheinlich sollte ich auch
härter trainieren
aber er war nicht sehr erfahren darin
wie man die risse hier klettert wir
kletterten die neues ein paar mal und
ich dachte mein gott wir werden sterben
er sicherte kaum klettert er schnell
aber nicht solid und ich dachte das wäre
ein desaster
dann stürzte er 30 meter ins seil war
zum glück unverletzt na ja leicht
angeschlagen aber nicht schwer und ich
dachte gott sei dank jetzt haben wir
eine entschuldigung aufzuhören
so verdienen habe ich eigentlich nie
passiert dass dynamik das ist das
problem
und dass er war er bereit wenn es drauf
ankommt auch mal dem glück zu vertrauen
ich kann das weniger wenn ich ihn zu
leute dass er alles für solos und
klettereien gemacht hatte dachte ich
manchmal dass günther bei heike du hast
das wirklich gemacht
dabei ist alex holt heute der inbegriff
des riskanten kletterers wieder am el
capitan wagte er 2017 die schwierigste
je ohne seil gekletterte route eine
sensation
ich wurde oft gefragt willst du das
wirklich tun und ich sagte ohne sein
balancierte er 1000 meter über dem
abgrund
im kinofilm fries solo wird alles mit
kameras festgehalten während der
filmaufnahmen stürzt ab ich war
schockiert als ich von moody's tod hörte
ich hätte nie erwartet dass ihm etwas
passiert ich brauchte lange das zu
verarbeiten
für mich sind meine vorbilder
unverletzlich es ist hart zu realisieren
dass jeder pech haben kann so
funktioniert statistik
ich dachte jemanden der so gut ist wie
uri dem stößt nichts zu
aber es kann halt doch jeden treffen
egal wie gut er ist dachtest du auch
selbst ein bisschen aber nicht wirklich
aber das ist es eben jeder glaubt von
sicher wäre vorsichtig
das dachte nur die natürlich auch
[Musik]
der mensch braucht irgendwoher user vor
die ja durch den focus zusammen
heute ist neben stickstoff und dass ich
genau dieses problem haben wir lange
dass man hier wie lange hier bis heute
nach
das heißt dass ich eben die schweizer
mentalität dass ich das problem reihe
schweizer also sicherheit und mehr
machen ist wenn massiv geld da ist die
totale katastrophe
aber wenn ich es akzeptieren sich nicht
100 prozent
wo muss bereit sie als risiko ist sich
der gefahr ist aber nicht viel
und die ganz mittig die führt einfach zu
extrem intensiven erlaube und das hat
suchtpotenzial also dass sich städte
clubs war mehr drin ist umweltliste
genug sich meistens noch alle
also eine schwierige wahl ist ich habe
immer mit anstatt zu
das ist das abenteuer richtig glauben
thürig immerhin unangenehme situation
und die roten bestrahlung user aber zu
einer beträgen ist so intensiv und wann
es dann noch gut machen wenn man merkt
es ist schwierig aber ich aus im griff
dann ist das so intensiv und gut und das
buch immer wieder
die herausforderung war ueli stecks
antrieb seine frau mit der er über viele
jahre verheiratet war möchte nicht vor
die kamera treten
sie schreibt uns sie hätte nicht immer
bewusst ob er von den schwierigen
expeditionen zurückkehren würde
sie habe erlebt wie er mit den
höhepunkten und tiefschlägen in seinem
leben gewachsen sei
gemeinsame erlebnisse in den bergen habe
beiden die kraft gegeben
schwierige situationen zu meistern
die zeit zu hause war für ueli steck
aber oft schon die vorbereitung für das
nächste abenteuer jetzt mal zehn monate
und 20 mal und gewann alle vier u von
sich oder vor das ist natürlich ein
mitglied räder im 1
ich habe vor expedition zurück woche
später vortrag die frage ist ja süchtig
nach dem projekt also das ist ja
irgendwie und so immer und tätig extrem
schwierig um alles lief wie der fuß vom
gas nahm
und das heißt eben so acocella dieses
ziel zu erreichen
ich würde aber es geht dabei aber
[Musik]
nach den alpen richtete uli steck seinen
fokus auf die hohen berge im himalaya es
ist wichtig gut auszusehen gegen dich
habe ich eh keine chance
trägst
[Musik]
mit ihm unterwegs der kanadier don budge
die menschen
ueli steck will testen die sein körper
die höhe verträgt
[Musik]
er war bereits auf der shisha pangma als
nächstes wartet der chio ein einstiegs
achttausender für bergsteiger aus der
ganzen welt
[Musik]
juli war hier bekannt das ist ganz
anders als bei willi er braucht für den
berg 18 stunden hier 18 tage lang nicht
das ist wirklich so
doch für einmal lief auch bei ueli steck
nicht alles rund
sein körper streikt
[Musik]
trotz magenverstimmung gibt er nicht auf
er kämpft sich auf dem gipfel eine neue
erfahrung für ihn gehen wir wieder
runter was richtiges essen ausruhen
[Applaus]
mein kopf velos werden und seine
magenprobleme
in einem hotel erholen sie sich von den
strapazen
wir sind in alarm um uns zu erholen für
fünf tage und so sieht sie aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das für nur 70 dollar pro tag
alles essen inklusive es ist wie las
vegas julis ältester bruder ronny wohnt
mit seiner familie in langnau im
emmental
auch er ist kein bergsteiger bestimmt
die situation am harz zum beispiel wenn
es verlockend
das voerder nehmen auch immer das
wirklich sind auch das toyota stets vom
start weg das den letzten rang ausländer
gesund also für mehr ist nach wie vor
sehr präsent
adwords ist die jüngste ich will ja
definitiv recht ruhig oder mir zu wenig
schläft worden
die geschwister fokussiert und ich
eigentlich immer glück 7 das reicht
eigentlich war es natürlich am 8
[Musik]
als uli steck 2015 alle viertausender
der alpen ohne auto und warnen
zurücklegte waren die brüder für einmal
gemeinsam unterwegs
oli wie immer voraus er probierte schaue
ich aber mit meiner fahrt der probleme
bewusst mental will aber voraus dass ich
die beste war blieben bei mit seiner
sexvideo und aber nicht das mit
geschätzten woche 2011 versuchte sich
ueli steck am höchsten berg den mount
everest von tibet aus direkt nach dem
chio
[Musik]
weißt du was wir haben eine heizung in
unserem zelt wieder mit dabei der
kanadier don bartolo ist er derjenige
der film
sie sind ohne sauerstoff unterwegs im
gegensatz zu fast allen anderen am berg
[Musik]
alle anderen teams hier oben in diesem
camp haben ständig diese atemmasken auf
wegen des sauerstoff
[Musik]
sie sehen aus wie die star wars figur
darth vader
wir kommen uns hier oben vor als wäre
rund um uns eine bombe losgegangen
[Musik]
den gipfel auf 8848 meter erreichten sie
nicht nur die steckkarte nur 100 meter
vor dem ziel um
er spürte wegen der kälte seine füße
nicht mehr
wer dies ein entscheidender punkt dass
man sagt hat jedes mal schickte und
sagte aber nirgendwo eine kaputt macht
und das ist ja interessant und im reeser
meer geschüttet und mit dem muster von
ungarn das ist genau der profi schickte
dann aber sie hält mutter bis vw ein
jahr später aber problem ist ich lag und
schlief ich nicht ganz zufrieden ist ist
ja wieder ist der praktisch der einzige
ohne sauerstoff
[Musik]
sein partner teddy war früher sherpa
heute ist er selber bergsteiger ueli
steck war sein mentor war ein langer tag
heute tendiert zu lange es ist wirklich
windig ja aber nicht kalt
aber auch nicht mehr als recht
sogar denn geschmeckt ich lese hält um
sofort auch so zu kippen hält das
gedacht dass acht von ihnen ist jetzt
ziemlich tragen da mache ich mir steht
der schalter hat er so ein spiel
vergisst
doch diesmal schaffte er es danach
wollte orly steck schwierigere wende
besteigen ihm war immer bewusst wie
gefährlich es ist mit bergsteiger
kollegen spricht er im everest basecamp
über seine ängste diese privataufnahmen
von john barry zeigen eine seite die er
normalerweise in der öffentlichkeit
nicht preisgab
[Musik]
ja weil es mehr von noch etwas geld noch
was geht nichts es ist eine typische
fragen und der hessen gehen und
unterstellte und die regierung die das
sens machen oder einfach so slowakische
sagen das risiko und die messmaschine
sonic trust shift von peer kluge
die starke franzose ich jede toros
profit logitech sei durch songs wie
stark fühlen
genau wie ihr schwebt machen oder metall
und sagt hey baby mit zenit direkt wenn
ihr leeres regal bedeutet noch nicht so
nicht ganz europa stiegen
über seine ängste zu weit zu gehen das
limit zu überschreiten
hat er mit seiner familie nie gesprochen
wird ein kredit also bewusst repariert
werden sorge machten bisher noch gut
dran handle was mobile information aller
macht und mehr einigkeit locker und
einfach möglich schwimmen und die hat
das auch so akzeptiert oder aber genau
gewusst
das sind mit dem umgeht und was hat das
mit dem umgang und das wort momentan bei
2 kann ist dass erlöse ältere maschinen
anderswo aber belasten
das ist krieg sie mich ist das gar nicht
vorstellen mit siegen die sättigen
situation angesehen und es ist eine
schwierigkeit für super sports machen
oder das ich denke dass gegen die nummer
ist das könnte man ist heute somit
wusste gar nicht was das bedeutet etwas
gemacht hat
[Musik]
in ampass reis david göttler jetzt zum
everest
ich gehe nach kambodscha everest
basecamp dann everest rennen so wie er
es früher nie gemacht hat
[Musik]
denn musik
maurizio pollini und robert bosch sind
ebenfalls richtung everest unterwegs
nicht zum bergsteigen sondern zum
fotografieren
[Musik]
welche themen kloster angekommen
eingeführt wurde
robert bosch war bei der bestattung von
orly dabei
auch die eltern waren damals nach nepal
gereist die brüder tauchten ein jahr
später in mollis welt ein
merkst du dass wieder richtige stimmlage
[Musik]
sehen der freude da irgendeine strafe
dass das einfach still
ich spüre jetzt auswendig das nomadische
unterliege hackl zwischenmenschlicher
warum er so große mining ag vor dem land
das herz begriffe und ich bitte sie das
nachvollziehen
mit dem groß ist kukksi ist aber einfach
uhr liest ex vertrauen in die menschen
in seiner zweiten heimat wurde 2013
erschüttert
er war unterwegs an den everest mit dem
italiener simone moro schon damals
plante er die beiden 8000 everest und
lotse zu verbinden
[Musik]
amberg kamen die sherpas in die quere
die fixseile für zahlende klienten
einrichteten
der italiener beleidigte die sherpas
das ganze eskalierte im lager weiter und
80 sherpas umringten die zelte wollten
genugtuung
uri steck saß mitten im zoom und so
schien es so als robust stellen heißt es
zahlt ihnen chancen bestehen dass sein
team hier ist weil die da bricht um ist
nicht diskutiert was passiert also ich
sehr sehr schlimme situation außer
kontrolle und die sherpas einfach blut
oder so
die hexe sie bringen nicht so dass ich
für kritik
und für mich ist so perfekt wie roman
der butt der wie so viele risiko ich
habe es irgendwie ausgegangen
und jetzt wie es im lager zu es von
europas und braucht dass ich so meine
gedanken könnte
mit der todesgefahr amberg konnte er
umgehen nicht aber mit dieser
lebensbedrohlichen situation durch
menschen mit denen er zusammengearbeitet
hatte die zwischen schlager geschichte
mit einer mit der sherpas das hat den
extremismus richtig und probierte so und
hilft wo direkt konnten und dass die
anstalt in dänischer einfach zusammen
ist das hat eine extrem beschäftigt ja
ich glaube das ist der deutsche taxi-
er brauchte lange um dieses trauma zu
verarbeiten
er zog sich zurück und trainierte nur
noch wollte mit der außenwelt lange
nichts mehr zu tun haben
etc aber wir sind super coole
trainingsstrecke von uns gewesen
5 millionen mehr als einfach diese
wirken sich im herzen von in grenzen
david göttler versucht alleine auf den
everest
er ist vermutlich der einzige ohne
sauerstoff in der menge am berg er trägt
nur eine kälte maske
es ist so voll dass er es nicht auf den
gipfel schafft
ohne sauerstoff hat er weniger reserven
und muss auf über 8000 metern umkehren
ihm wird der kommerz am everest zum
verhängnis
[Musik]
auf den schlafsack verzichten
wenn wir aber so ganz schön kalt
deswegen die ich jetzt damit er noch
hinter der 2 so wie der uli mal gesagt
hat das ist mir irgendwie immer hängen
geblieben dass man da oben ja schauen
was erstmal keinen spaß machen
[Musik]
an den hohen bergen kann ein zögern der
kleinste fehler zur katastrophe führen
dessen war sich oli steck bewusst
vor 20 jahren keine klettern vor dem
fest bei step zudem auskömmlichen
bergsteiger wurde und beim sind die 34
fähigkeiten zusammen was braucht zum
selbermachen sehr großes technisches
können
erfolg oder höhere berge große mentale
stärke und tarnow die u haft
was es heißt sich an hohen bergen zu
exponieren erlebte uhr liest eck an der
annapurna einer der gefährlichsten
achttausender schon 2007 reizte ihn die
schwierige südwand mit dabei roberts mit
so viel schnee richtig schon immer den
richtigen duft wir mit skill sich die
orangen nicht so schlimm aber doppelwand
bin überzeugt das fahrzeug mit lawine
und mitglied griechische spieler kann
sie verstehen
die route stünde für einen neuen
schwierigkeitsgrad dem himalaya
bergsteigen steck will sie alleine ohne
fremde hilfe versuchen robert bosch
begleitet ihn zum wandfuß
zurück
doch kaum los geklettert stürzt er ab
[Musik]
wissen sie sport
einstein hat ihn getroffen er erinnert
sich an nichts und die trifft sehr
wahrscheinlich und zwar genau bekannt
die gestaltung so wie hier in südafrika
was ganz bewusst sind verloren hat aber
so einen berg bei einer üblichen oben
bist
nur ein jahr später versuchte er es
erneut diesmal zu zweit dann ein
hilferuf
[Musik]
der spanier inaki ochoa ist höhenkrank
wurde steckt ein team mit medikamenten
zu hilfe ohne richtige ausrüstung die
schon in einem anderen lager ist nach
zwei tagen erreicht er ihn dem spanier
geht es schlecht er bleibt bei ihm im
zelt bis dieser stirbt
[Musik]
um jemand anderen zu helfen erreicht oli
steck sein ziel wieder nicht
[Musik]
jahre vergehen bis es ohne steckt zum
dritten mal versucht
[Musik]
einem französischen kamerateam erklärt
er was ihn antreibt
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten versuch habe ich zuerst
gedacht ich gehe nicht so
das ist nicht mein berg erst jetzt nach
fünf jahren bin ich wieder hier beginnst
nachzudenken es lässt dich nicht los
ich habe es nie richtig versucht ich
hatte nie richtig die chance ist
wirklich zu versuchen wieder mit dabei
der kanadier die route an der annapurna
geht 2600 m
die südwand hoch über einen schwierigen
face regel bis hinauf auf den gipfel auf
8091 meter höhe die verhältnisse
scheinen dieses jahr perfekt
doch dann ein dämpfer ich bin um drei
uhr aufgewacht mit schmerzen im hals
jedes mal wenn ich nach nepal komme
werde ich krank
ich weiß nicht ob es der staub in
kathmandu ist meine lungen sind langsam
anfällig
ueli steck will unbedingt hin auf große
berge können angst machen und nehmen
auch ueli steck kennt diese angst aber
er will sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
ja wir müssen es versuchen
ja ich verstehe dass ich will auch wenn
wir zu lange warten haben wir nur eine
nacht
ich will wieder unten sein wenn das
wetter umschlägt
am tag an dem der sturm angesagt ist bin
ich wieder hier
[Musik]
der kanadier john barry ist
gesundheitlich wieder fit und die beiden
brechen auf doch als es losgeht sagte
und bolli plötzlich er komme nicht mit
ehrlich gesagt ich habe da oben kein
gutes gefühl gehabt
es ist eine schwierige rallye ist eine
der besten wenn nicht der beste
bergsteiger der welt
ich bin einfach nicht so gut wie er das
gelände war mir zu schwierig und dann
hatten wir auch noch ziemlich
steinschlag als wir letztes mal oben
waren
ich kam ja so alleine da bin ich halt
einfach los gegangen
ich gehe hoch zum oberen lager schauen
wie die bedingungen sind
keine sorge ich melde mich
obwohl es sich allein gelassen fühlt er
gibt nicht auf
er ist allein in der großen wand
es hat viel wind und gefährliche
schneelawinen und er stürzt deswegen
fast ab
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich konnte mich nur noch an den pickeln
festhalten
dann hat es gedrückt und gedrückt
irgendwann hört es auf gefallen in dem
moment ist bei mir ein schalter
umgekippt am anfang war alles easy
dort habe ich realisiert du bist allein
in einer riesigen wand und vielleicht
kommst du nie mehr nach hause
ich war wirklich völlig ausgesetzt dann
habe ich es einfach akzeptiert dann
kommst du halt nicht mehr nach hause
[Musik]
er hat doch gesagt wir nehmen den warmen
schlafsack mit ich wusste er meint es
ernst weil er sein telefon nicht vom
basecamp hoch gebracht hat seine
kollegen unten im lager haben keine
ahnung was sich oben am berg abspielt
wir müssen abwarten bis zum morgen
vielleicht sehen wir seine lampen oder
er kommt plötzlich in unser zelt mitten
in der nacht wie steck ist oben in
seiner eigenen welt erwartet in einer
gletscherspalte bis sich der wind legt
klettert weiter und kommt in der nacht
auf den gipfel
[Musik]
freiheit ist wenn du so groß ist auch
die mittelschicht und der hand auf die
skydsl und das hat er realisiert und
darum hat er sich entschlossen und sich
auf dem gipfel war war ich gar nicht
sicher ob ich wirklich oben war es war
dunkel dann ist mir plötzlich
aufgegangen
oh mein gott ich bin hier auf 8.000
meter unter mir sind 2600 meter du
willst nur noch runter nach hause
die freunde unten bangen am morgen
taucht er wieder auf
ganze 28 stunden lang ist er unterwegs
gewesen
siehst du dich
das geht mir zu schnell
ich bin todmüde aber seit mehr als 24
stunden nicht geschlafen war fast die
ganze zeit in bewegung
es waren wirklich wahnsinnig gute
bedingungen
das hatte ich auch an der shisha pangma
das hast du nur einmal im leben
und dann musst du einfach gehen
du kommst wie von einem anderen planeten
zurück ich konnte meinen kollegen nicht
erklären was ich da oben erlebt habe
ueli steck hat damit eine neue dimension
im bergsteigen aufgezeigt so schnell
völlig allein
das hatte noch nie jemand geschafft ich
war bereit sehe sogar zu sterben
das hatte ich noch nie nur so kannst du
wahrscheinlich so etwas sonst machst du
das nicht in diesem stil
für diesen berg war er bereit sein leben
zu lassen
die tragik der geschichte er hatte
keinen beweis dafür dass er tatsächlich
oben war aber ruhig und ich meinte hat
krankenhaus verlor und der unterbrechung
darf wieder zurückkehrt so glatt bei
gosee druck was ich liebe jahre auf brot
hat das ideale verfolgt das projekt und
dann ist das aus weg und dann kommt
relativ schlafrock nach es bewiesen
und dann muss uns jetzt einfach gemacht
sie ist also wahr meint war damit
wirklich sehr voll
er hat den karl kamer wer hat der hat
alle tätig
ueli steck wurde als lügner betitelt
selbst gute freunde glaubten ihm nicht
das ist läuft das keltische los und ja
ich glaub so viel zeit im büro wie den
hätten wir vorher nachher kommt der chef
dass das nicht glaube das ist für mich
nicht nachvollziehbar gläubiger mensch
gesehen dass das für ihn nicht
vorstellbar ist dass das nicht glaubt
[Musik]
der höhepunkt war auch ein tiefpunkt er
spürte dass es zeit war mit dem extrem
bergsteigen aufzuhören
bei einem seiner sponsoren unterschrieb
er für eine neue karriere als
produktdesigner
[Musik]
2017 wollte er aber noch ein letztes
großes projekt wagen er war 40 jahre alt
so fit wie noch nie erneut sein plan die
verbindung der achttausender everest und
lotse ohne sauerstoff das hatte noch nie
ein mensch geschafft
es ist uns tut probleme erstmal geschäft
nehmen und der abstieg und durch
erfolgreichen exit also mache ich jetzt
nicht gegen die ticket also eine für
mitgefühl das ist das risiko und für
mich solls bewusst das projekt und
gewalt poliert merkt also ihr mich die
letzten jahre von der niveau bewegt und
ich weiß wenn ich wenn ihn sowie der
fahrer des letztjährigen meister uns
nicht gut und das projekt endlich für
mehr sportliche challenge aber ich will
sportlich dynamisch ende der marke oder
magnet nicht irgendwie ap die aktion
das projekt würde er zusammen mit seinem
freund angie schärfer angehen mit dem er
2012 schon am everest war zu fuß erleben
rest der wird normal und abstiege
südkorea und ihnen dadurch ihre
millionen in normalen davon nutze hofer
gipfel und wenn man mal der tgs graditz
westen kommt wieder frei
ich glaube zu mir kam das ist das letzte
mal war daher kommt oder und bis 6 m 8
am everest oder dass sich wohin die
hätte show gedanke dazu will ich so an
der sache machen oder aber langsam zu
aber fahrer denke das ist normal
kurz vor seiner abreise ging er mit dem
vater noch auf eine skitour
[Musik]
schon die beworbene schnäppchen warten
wir die woche kamen cloud termin steht
aus ja hamburger auf der bahn ja immer
der tag an dem sport damit
[Musik]
das vergesse ich nie
die letzten aufnahmen von ueli steck im
everest basecamp
[Musik]
drei jahre ist es nun her dass in seine
freunde robert bosch und maurizio
pollini im everest basecamp treffen
wollten
der zufall will es dass auch tempeh
sherpa hier oben ist mit dem ueli steck
eigentlich nach dem nutzer auf den
everest wollte
[Musik]
er war wie mein bruder es war eine der
schwierigsten zeiten in meinem leben ich
werde nie vergessen auch nicht was ich
von ihm gelernt haben
[Musik]
ich habe 26
und ich meine dass ich dir warum weiß
keiner so ganz geteilt das ist aber
nicht und die intensität wo man beim
richtigen erlebt und ich glaube dass ich
war auch sicher dort trainiert das hat
geklappt
eigentlich wollte orly steck auf dem
normalen weg richtung everest um sich an
die höhe zu gewöhnen
doch dann lockte ihn doch wieder die
herausforderung der nutzer
möglicherweise hatte er diesen berg als
drittem nach everest und lotse ins auge
gefasst
nun ist rox ernährung die funktion mit
sicherheit sehr gut gelaufen und ich
habe es geht nie besser ist bemerkte
spitz war es ist zwar schwierig aber ich
aus dem griff in die gut vorwärts und
drogen passiert ist der olympische zu
werden wo man glücklicher mensch
[Musik]
abschied nach
heute erinnert im bergsteiger friedhof
am everest eine stupa manuell staeck
an seinen drang neues zu wagen sich
selber zu übertreffen
in tibet heißt ein sprichwort lieber
einen tag als tiger als 1000 tage lang
ein schaf
[Musik]